si c'est pas les oil stage place au rock
quand vous femmes ont voulu une ses
rapides couple croyez vous qu'elle avait
ça l'esprit j'en suis persuadé nous
sommes un couple de couple pas vrai bein
ted ça suffit vos délires
vous n'avez pas voyager dans le temps et
vous n'êtes à l'ennemi au paradis en
enfer
je vais vous donner un bon conseil
servait d'exemple amont filles les gars
trouvez vous un vrai emploi
[Musique]
c'est fait à peu près 25 ans qu'on
s'acharne a composé cette chanson et je
suis fatigué de houtain nous avons un
destin accomplir
salut à vous mes excellents amis nous
avons un problème
avancez vous une chanson créée par
prestement de lyon
[Musique]
prêté ce soir à la réalité telle qu'on
la connaît au doute pour mieux qu'on
compose vite cette chanson peut-être
qu'on devrait aller dans le futur au
moment où la dèche est recomposée on
s'inspire de noël mais ce sera pas du
vol c'est pourquoi ce serait du vol si
c'est à nous mêmes que nous l'avons non
deux noms perdront définitivement a pas
besoin de moi
mais leur donner un coup de main
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai que le mans savent habile
et aides en forme il plus fabuleux des
groupes de musique
vous voulez faire partie de notre groupe
[Musique]
faucon être parlé à faucheurs est ce
qu'il est en train de jouer à la marelle
mais il est tout jeune
12 il est en train de tricher ça lui
fait peur si c'est pas les wild style
place au rock
soyez excellent les envers les sourds
trouvé que la fête continue tout
bon ça va
bah on est mort tu sais est en enfer
mais sinon ça va ça va